I think the kind of question to be good
to ask is what's good about our
condition not just what's bad about it
and how do we get get here how do we get
to enjoy it well not just what went
wrong which it's very easy to ask but
also what went right also the other
question I would want people to ask is
what really is our current state of
affairs how bad are things compared to
other times in places how polluted is
our environment compared to the way it
was a hundred years ago how much war and
peace is there compared to what there
was at other times how much murder and
rape and homicide get an objective
picture of our current state of affairs
so as to have a rational basis for
asking what went right in the things
that we do value how can we bottle it
and purify it and concentrate it so that
we can enjoy more of whatever that is in
the future